CBS News has learned one of President
Trump's personal valets has tested
positive for the coronavirus Ballet's
help with personal tasks and even serve
the president meals
the president has tested negative but
this is raising questions about whether
the administration is following its own
guidelines Paula Reid is at the White
House Paula what do we know
good morning Anthony CBS News has
learned that this valet started feeling
sick on Tuesday and tested positive on
Wednesday President Trump told reporters
yesterday that both he and the Vice
President have subsequently been tested
and they are both negative but they will
both now be tested daily and that is a
change in the protocol here at the White
House and a stark contrast to the
experience of many Americans who have
difficulty even getting a test as the
president urges the country to reopen
now the president the vice president
they're not expected to self quarantine
even though the current federal
guidelines say if you come into contact
with someone who's positive you should
self quarantine for 14 days unless
though the guidelines say you are an
essential worker then you're expected to
take protective measures but it's
unclear if the president or vice
president will take any additional
protective measures today they host a
group of world war two veterans to
commemorate the 75th anniversary of
Victory Day but this is raising some
concerns that this could potentially
expose a high-risk group to the virus
even as the White House continues to
urge older Americans to shelter in place
Gail
all right Paula thank you very much